à versailles les curieux et passionnés
de littérature ainsi que d'histoires
sont servis la bibliothèque municipale
propose des visites guidées insolites du
bâtiment un parcours et des secrets à
découvrir avec nicolas landry et les
arrêts ch
attention parce que c'est là qu'on veut
c'est là que nous entrons dans notre
petit labyrinthe la famille moutou et
transportés à travers les époques
lors des deux heures de visite guidée
dans les murs de la bibliothèque
municipale de versailles
ici sont conservées plus de 700 mille
ouvrages en plus ou moins en bon état
mais s'ils cachent aussi des tableaux et
des sculptures car le bâtiment est un
ancien musée la visite insolite permet
de présenter diverses époques diverses
pièces patrimoniale
l'idée c'est de montrer que le parcours
épouse un peu l'histoire particulière de
ce bâtiment qui est l'ancien hôtel des
affaires étrangères de la marine et que
la bibliothèque a peu à peu colonisé ce
haut lieu de l'histoire de france a
également été le témoin de traités
internationaux
évidemment vous êtes dans le bâtiment où
a été signé alors pas signé mais
élaborer le traité d'indépendance des
états unis
donc les américains ont toujours eu dit
comment dire une certaine amitié
les avis de versailles la visite
s'adapte à tous les publics et regorge
d'anecdotes qui passionne les grands
comme les petits
il faut savoir que nous avons hérité
tout à fait légalement par par notaire
d'un fantôme
d'ailleurs ce monsieur a un nom il
s'appelle monsieur lenfle un parent dont
des photos c'est le fantôme
si tu l'as laissé un mot donc on verra
revue historique bulletin roman ou
encore périodiques les sous-sols
révèlent leurs richesses qui passionne
tant les visiteurs
on aime beaucoup les livres le bâtiment
est exceptionnel et les livres en fête
retrace toute une histoire et je trouve
qui est souvent méconnu les visites
insolites vous donne rendez vous sur
inscription tous les samedis matin